monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Madame Marie-Christine Daloz pour le
groupe les républicains
merci merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
madame la Première ministre si notre
système de retraite par répartition est
bien menacée par des déficits à venir la
seule considération du prisme financier
ne règlera qu'une partie des problèmes
vous le savez les députés les
républicains sont très attachés et
d'ailleurs peut-être les seuls à
beaucoup en parler elle a revalorisation
des petites retraites vous avez répondu
à notre attente en acceptant d'étendre
le dispositif de 1200 euros au retraitée
actuel
vous avez également annoncé dimanche
ouvrir le dispositif des carrières
longues à ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler entre 20 et 21 ans ces
personnes pourront ainsi partir à 63 ans
avec 43 à nuités une retraite pleine au
lieu de 44 à nuitées et nous vous en
remercions la difficulté qui persiste
concerne les personnes qui ont une
carrière longue voire très longue avant
leur 18 ans en effet pour ces personnes
une durée de carrière de 44 ans sera
nécessaire pour atteindre une retraite à
taux plein comment comprendre ces
différences ou cette pénalité d'un an
qui desservira les Français qui ont
commencé à travailler très jeune avant à
18 ans ou avant 18 ans et je pense
notamment aux apprentis aux métiers
manuels et il y en a beaucoup dans nos
circonscriptions comptez-vous améliorer
le dispositif pour l'ensemble de ces
personnes et enfin répondre à une
attente légitime